pues hay todavía incertidumbre porque el
primer ministro sigue en el poder ha
dicho que estará hasta cuando se elija a
su sucesor que podría hacer a finales de
septiembre o de octubre pero lo cierto
es que ha iniciado dentro del partido
conservador una disputa sobre si johnson
debe mantenerse o no en el cargo hasta
que se elija a su sucesor es bien
importante esto que está sucediendo en
este día sin precedentes aquí en el
reino unido porque el ex primer ministro
conservador del partido del que johnson
es líder hasta el momento hay un mayor
ha escrito una carta al jefe del partido
de la comité 1922 que es ese comité que
puede sacar a los primeros ministros y
le ha dicho que por el bienestar del
país boris johnson no debe seguir en
downstream que tres meses son muchos y
sugirió además que dominique el rap
debería
convertirse en el primer ministro
encargado del es el vice primer ministro
en este momento o también ha sugerido
que los conservadores deben acelerar el
de elección de johnson así que ha
iniciado entonces una nueva disputa
política sobre si johnson debe o no
quedarse hasta que se elija su sucesor o
debe salir así que veremos como son
recibidas estas palabras estas
sugerencias del ex primer ministro john
major entretanto la población siente que
es necesario que asuma el poder
rápidamente una persona que pueda sacar
al país de tantas necesidades
especialmente estaba crisis fuertísima
del costo de vida y la inflación
luisa nosotros también lo hemos
digamos hablado aquí en el franz 24
también en nuestro programa directo
américa a todos los escándalos por lo
que ha pasado en estos últimos meses el
primer ministro británico boris johnson
recordemos entonces cuáles han sido los
principales que lo han llevado a ese
momento de tensar la cuerda y decir ya
no hay más por la presión interna de su
gobierno
son varios y el más grave sin duda es el
party del que tú has hablado durante
toda la mañana durante el confinamiento
por la pandemia del hobbit 19 cuando
este país es uno de los más poderosos
del mundo estuvo prácticamente cerrado
se conoció posteriormente que en las
oficinas de edad un instruir el complejo
de las oficinas del primer ministro y
donde además vivía y además en otras
instalaciones del gobierno se habían
realizado al menos 12 fiestas ilegales
en las que habría asistido además la
familia de jones fue multado justamente
por la celebración de su cumpleaños
mientras millones de personas morían y
pasaban dificultades para poder
despedirse de sus seres queridos por
esta pandemia tan difícil otro bien
recordado es la renovación de su
apartamento en downing street
boris johnson y su esposa contrataron a
una reconocida diseñadora de interiores
pero el presupuesto oficial para
ese objeto no era suficiente así que voy
johnson tuvo que pedirle y hay chats
escritos sobre justamente esa petición
que hizo a uno de los donantes del
partido conservador a otro escándalo que
está vinculado con quienes soy su esposa
gaby johnson es que trato de conseguirle
en de fertilidad en diferentes
oportunidades un trabajo de alto nivel
primero cuando fue secretario de
exteriores y también ha reportado la
prensa que más recientemente con la
cumbre del clima con 26 en glasgow y el
último como lo mencionas que fue esa
gota que derramó la copa porque johnson
negó inicialmente saber sobre las
acusaciones de acoso sexual contra quien
fuera el jefe de disciplina del partido
christopher luego por el
escándalo que se armó en el país tuvo
que decir que sí que sí sabía pero que
lo había olvidado así que una vez más
dicen aquí boris johnson ha demostrado
que tiene dificultades con la verdad